les etats-unis ont annoncé avoir adopté
des sanctions contre cette personne
physique et 14 organisations suspecté
d'avoir pris part à l'élaboration
d'armes biologiques ou chimiques
il s'agit là de la première action
concrète de l'administration by donne à
l'encontre de la russie
le renseignement américain estime avec
je cite un haut degré de confiance que
des agents du fsb ont utilisé un agent
innervant pour empoisonner alexeï
navalni ces sanctions
cherchez donc à punir la russie dans le
cadre de la sphère navalni mais aussi
pour l' ingérence présumée dans les
élections américaines ou encore avec
l'accusation d' attaque informatique
contre solar wind pour l'instant on ne
connaît pas encore l'identité des
personnes et des organisations visées au
contraire des sanctions européennes en
effet quelques minutes avant l'annoncé
américaine l'union européenne publiée
officiellement les noms des quatre hauts
responsables russes impliqués d'après
bruxelles dans l'empoisonnement supposé
d'alexey la vanille ces quatre personnes
sont toutes des hauts fonctionnaires le
procureur général le chef du comité
d'investigation celui de la garde
nationale ainsi que le directeur des
services pénitentiaires
place maintenant à la réaction de moscou
en effet sergueï lavrov plus tôt dans la
journée a promis que ces sanctions
européennes comme américaines ne
resterait pas sans réponse